Ljubljana yes Viviana where'd you grow
up are you from I'm from Milwaukee
Wisconsin Milwaukee and you grew up with
both parents or one parent or as you
grow both parents kind of like I had a
stepdad and then put two stepdads I
didn't really meet my real dad in 2015
also I guess you could say I have like I
said it's done that yeah how old are you
know about to be 19 five minutes you're
18 you're gonna be 19 yes and how was
your childhood
okay like what do you mean like well I
mean like were there any issues problems
how do you along with your stepdads I
mean pretty well I know they always had
my best interests at heart
my mom it was it was just tough because
like when I turned I was nine years old
my mom she got turned out to shine you
know and disappear right PCP and you
know she heard mine she just wasn't
really aware of what's going on you know
anything as far as like her children
exactly so at a young age like me my mom
my our our relationship was kind of off
you know but my stepdad really there
like that thing one of my stepdads he
was in another jail you know so you can
basically say I was raised by my mother
but and then when I was 13
maybe yes 13 I was taken away from my
mom
and put in CPS custody because she I got
so high off sure like she found her like
blacked out and yeah why I went to my
aunties and things really didn't go well
there because like I had like people
trying to sexually abused me there and
stuff like that so then it was weird
because I was so fast at the time you
know like me transitioning to a teenager
I didn't really understand what my
auntie was like trying to keep me away
from like boys and stuff like that so I
got pregnant and then right yeah and
then I ended up getting an abortion
sadly I know it seems a mistake and in
the at your aunt's house the people that
were trying to molest you were her son
yeah so so that led me to like run away
and then I had to leave my twin sister
and so that was kind of sad it took a
toll on me because I didn't want to
leave her but at the same time he was
like was I gonna go back and he abused
and then hope like you know saying
something to my child so I was just like
I don't want anything like I don't want
no type of responsibility of that you
know anything cuz I would know how to
live with myself something happened to
my child on my water you know under my
care so it was just like so then I ran
away and I went home to my grandmother
Lucy she's like 96 she's still living
that's a good thing but and I stayed
with Harry for about like six months
this is all this is in st. Louis I
actually went to st. Louis yes okay so
you went from Wisconsin to st. Louis
yeah yeah
and I won with my grandma I stayed with
her for a while I kind of like looked
after her and stuff and then I went and
my sister she picked me up and I stayed
with my sister for a while
and helping her out and things like that
and then I got myself back in school my
sister put me through school because you
know with me leaning and stuff like that
yes oh I'm actually in college right now
yes but it's just kind of hard like to
like you know maintain because the kind
of work field that I mean yeah how long
you been working sister
when did you start I actually started
like Kabir how does an 18 year old
working this trick you have to have to
be 21 then William some you do I mean
you know all the rules don't apply to
you
he know and I'm saying you figure out
ways around it but um my first job I
worked at blue homes in Arizona like on
the 32nd in van well it's an instance
kind of like Scottsdale area it's really
nice
you know discreet I started working
there because I quit my job at Red
Lobster
you know it's like I wasn't making
enough money and then I feel
unappreciated like I was devalued you
know so I was just like you know what
since I'm already serving and acting
like you know I'm saying like they
already treating me like a peasant
anyway like give me one dollar some
people like me two cents like what the
the Freak am I gonna do - since you know
how you gonna pay your base how you
gonna pay the bills of that I was
talking with my friend and she was
basically saying like all you got a
bangin body like you sure you should
come work with me or they auditioning on
Sunday so I was just like at first I was
like no way my family's gonna see me you
know what I'm saying because even though
my mom was like doing drugs and stuff
like that she was like my mom was a
registered nurse before she did all you
know
like she got turned out to things like
that like it can happen to anybody but
like I like you know my family they
still they're still humans you know
they're not everybody's - row headers
and then like that so it's just like oh
my god they're gonna see me naked or
what if they what if they find out it's
just like once I did it it was like oh
it's like I got my own life to live you
know so I went to the audition and the
lady Kendra she liked me she was like
you're cute she was like but when you're
up there cuz like I guess there's a
thing that everybody does everything
moves so fast when you own the place
they moved so fast and she told me
because I'm black I have to move slower
you know like so it was kind of
adjustments in the industry as well like
you know be me being the skin complexion
that I am you know like it's not easy
for every door to be open to you you
know so it's just like like it was like
all okay I'm in a strip club
hopefully I'm gonna meet him about 5,000
okay I'm gonna make is this you know but
grass is not always greener on the other
side you know that's cons and pros to me
as well
you know like safety hazards and stuff
like my safety is number one you know
before it was like I used to walk around
like already money was nothing to me so
I started working up in the club you
know being started happening but as far
as me more being a stripper do you urge
another close to
yes well like under the table kinda
Nassau so I mean when you're working as
a stripper sometimes the guys want extra
favorites can you make extra money doing
that
oh no um actually you can I've seen
other girls do it but I've never done it
you don't do know how much do you make
it a night
well it all depends cuz you know and one
night you can walk out with five bins
next night and walk out with three
dollars you know djinji it just all
depends you know it's like it's good it
has good days and his bad days but I
fell off some shows so I guess all I
could say I make about like 5 600 on
like a bad day but on a good day
probably like a thousand or two you know
it all depends on who's in how slowly as
you get me the hours right right I was
about to say hourly I don't know pay
hourly or like a loose contact you start
late you finish yes well wait till
they've come in from like 9:00 to 4:00
right so it's like I'm like
sleep-deprived you know I'm there I
can't really focus like that so that's
why I said it's kind of hard to go to
school go to college and then maintain
my stripper and then also like like
people they like I've seen guys have
come to the club and they be at my
school so it's like it's it's so weird
like I don't want to just like I don't
know it's really like so it's like my
life is so public you give me so it's
not like it's so discrete anymore so
that's where I just like keep my
emotions you know turn that switch off
like you know that I don't care who
knows what I'm doing
you know I gotta put food in my mouth
just like that and whatever your plans
for the future really good well are
actually include like I'm studying
medical right now like I'm in school
like PCT it's patient care technician so
basically like I'm gonna be able to like
like draw blood CPR and stuff just stuff
like that and then they're gonna throw
in like a CNA course stuff you know what
I'm talking about like I'll be seeing a
register so before you become a
registered nurse you have to have your
CNA you have to be CNA certified so
that's what I'm trying to get I'm
exploring down to be seen any certified
and then after that I'll go fetch the
nursing it all depends like I'm just I'm
like I'm young it's only 18 I'm so
confused like how can you be a stripper
and then being a nurse but then you know
what I've heard people you know I heard
a lot of testimony son never seen